[Musique]
nouvelle programmation planétarium rio
tinto alcan ou menu deux projections en
format 3d
la première fait état de la possible
découverte d'une neuvième planète dans
notre système solaire une planète plus
grosse et massive que la terre qui se
trouverait au delà de la ceinture
d'astéroïdes de kayes peur de découvrir
potentiellement une nouvelle planète
dans notre propre système solaire
au moment où on est en train de trouver
des exoplanètes en dehors du système
solaire c'était tout à fait approprié le
film résume les travaux d'un
astrophysicien mike brown connu
également pour avoir contribué à retirer
à plus dans son statut de planète
au delà de l'orbité neptune on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya à peu près un
million d'objets méconnu donc vraiment
une
une pluralité de et c'est pour ça je
parler d'eux ou planétaires dans notre
propre système solaire
la technologie de projection de planètes
neufs de type faute d'hommes 360 est
spectaculaire et plusieurs effets
spéciaux en mettre plein la vue aux
spectateurs
j'articule tellement de choses à
découvrir dans l'espace
on est tout petit sur la terre on s'en
rend pas toujours compte le 3d est
également très efficace pour le deuxième
spectacle les secrets de la gravitation
présenté sous forme d'animations qui
évoque les théories d'einstein la
masquer le temps l'espace et autres
matières plus ou moins facile d'accès un
pouvoir expliquer la relativité générale
oui on peut le faire lors d'une
conférence on peut le faire sur un
tableau à l'école mais avoir un thomas
disposition ça c'est extrêmement
précieux encore une fois le gâteau lève
sans effort j'adore parce que c'est
relaxant puis j'apprends beaucoup de
choses mais s'il vulgariser la théorie
de la relativité aux enfants quelque
chose de pas évident et je pense qu'ils
ont bien réussi les deux projections
adapté pour le public québécois ont été
primés à plusieurs reprises dans le
monde ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal